[Music]
no doesn't feel so good we feel a little
uncomfortable feel bad saying no no -
something is yes - something else and
that's the first thing you need to think
about to give yourself permission to say
no my husband actually put a sticky note
on my computer for about a year with the
word no on it and it really did give me
permission to say no and to remember
that that's allowed so that's the first
thing then you want to think about how
to say no and how to say yes because yes
and no are never one-word answers my
favorite on the know side is no but no
not this not right now no but I could do
this instead no but this person might be
interested I look - given no with the
opportunity for a yes later for example
somebody asked me to do a pro bono talk
happy to do those things if they meet
certain criteria this criteria was
driving two hours in rush hour to talk
to 30 people it wasn't gonna meet that
criteria and I said if you can get X
number of people in the room and we can
do it you know during this time of day
then I'm happy to do it
so no but here's how you can get a yes
is a great way to enable somebody to
feel okay and for you to feel okay
and not want to avoid that extended
relationship so when we use a no but we
give them an opportunity for a yes down
the road but we also can use the no but
to help them find another way to get
that help
no but there's this great resource you
may want to look into no but I do know
somebody who's working on that let me
ask if they might be interested in
connecting no but I might not be able to
help you but I'm happy to give you ideas
on how you can get the help you're
looking for sometimes you want to and
get to say yes so we want to sometimes
qualify our yes yes if yes if you can
get this done for me or yes if you can
get this many people in the room or yes
if it could be yes after yes
I could love to get on the phone with
you after I'm done with this big project
that I'm working on or after I get back
from vacation just giving yourself a
little breathing room in when and the
timing of when that follow-through will
actually happen so we have yes if we
have yes after we could have yes with
yes with your assistance or yes with
another party I'm happy to work on that
yes with some training so yes if yes
after yes with or even yes when and when
could be when I feel that I'm really
ready to do that yes when I have gotten
that training that we talked about yes
when so all of these things help give
you a little bit of space and manage the
expectations of the follow-through of
that yes
[Music]